a barely-there thong a bedsheet and is
that an office chair that's all you need
apparently to whip up an Internet storm
so a photographer mert Alice posted this
behind-the-scenes pic of Selina from
their recent photo shoot on his
Instagram captioning it Beauty and the
Beast but some fans are quick to point
out that but barring shot goes against
Selena's recent statements on self-worth
after making her post rehab urged her at
the American Music Awards back in
November she said this in her powerful
speech I don't want to see your bodies
on Instagram I want to see what's in
here
I'm not trying to get validation nor do
I need it anymore
the singer is already taking heed from
online trolls after steamy pics were
released of her and the weekend
yesterday making out I can't keep my
hands to myself another tiny problem it
seems to have brushed her good friend
and Able's axe the wrong way Bella Hadid
has now unfollowed Selena on Instagram
but is still keeping tabs on the weekend
some fans believe miss Gomez knew paps
were outside the celeb packed Santa
Monica restaurant where this shot was
taken and deliberately wanted to grab
headlines go head sources tell E the
couple initially wanted to keep their
relationship a secret but recently
decided they really don't care if
everyone knows about them and even
though their romance is still in its
early days the weekend recently admitted
to GQ I feel like I'm the kind of guy
that would have kids before getting
married
the first thing would be kids marriage
is scary to me man